but first this was meant to be the week
when the UK's deal with UK with the EU
was signed and sealed but with no
agreement on the tricky issue of the
Irish border there was still deadlock to
break the impasse the two sides might
agree to a longer transition period but
that brings its own problems with Brick
City MPs in Westminster set to oppose
any move which keeps Britain tied to EU
rules for longer than necessary so to
try and wade our way through all of this
I'm joined in the studio now by the
brexit Minister Sue Ellen
rather than thank you very much for
being with us this morning now before we
get to this or nitty-gritty of the
negotiations just want to take a bit of
a step back last month's summit ended an
impasse as Theresa May said last week
the talks again break up with no
agreement now that you saying they may
as well be no summit next month because
there's not been enough progress made I
mean at what point do we start to panic
I think progress is actually going very
well on our brexit negotiations and
we've actually made huge progress on a
green certain aspects with the EU issues
which this time last year were deemed to
be intractable things like the position
of EU citizens we've agreed an
implementation period with the EU we've
resolved issues to do with governments
and dispute register why this huge
progress that's been made why is this
summit not on the card so next month
well we have actually made this progress
in the draft legal treaty relating to
our withdrawal as I say technical legal
complex and that should be applauded it
doesn't always get the headlines the
good news and the progress unfortunately
but it's definitely real and on the
other hand we've also got to remember
how the EU negotiates I don't think
there's ever been a treaty or an
agreement that the EU has struck which
hasn't been agreed at the final hour in
their timeline so it's not time for
panicking it's time for staying calm and
staying focused on the goal which we're
all on track to secure and that you've
previously said that knowdo would be
great do you still think that's true
No Deal will be will be something that
this country will will be able to
survive it won't be a walk in the park
but it won't be a disaster either our
country will be able to put in place
whatever needs to be done we will ensure
that
continues to flow smoothly we will be
able to get through it it's not the
ideal outcome
let's not there you know beat about the
bush on that but definitely we can
thrive in an ideal situation as well
okay well let's talk about the movement
their latest movement shall we say the
Brits at secretary Dominic Robb talking
about this possible extension to the
implementation period or the transition
period is that something that you could
accept we need to keep it in context of
the negotiations so we have as we've
rightly said a difficulty with the Irish
backstop with the EU and the EU have put
forward a proposal which is completely
unacceptable to the UK which would carve
off Northern Ireland essentially the
backstop is something that we don't
expect to use it's an insurance policy
in our last resort so this is about a
kind of an issue which is something we
don't think will be realised but we have
to resolve it in either sense and what
the Secretary of State for exiting the
EU Dominic Robb has put forward today
and echoing the sentiments of the Prime
Minister is that potentially bear in
mind this is all still part of a
negotiation and not an agreed position
potentially extending the implementation
period by a few months if that would
resolve this backstop issue so in other
words getting a video so in other words
it's saying that if the EU drops its
demand for this backstop then the
transition could be extended it's a bit
of a quid pro quo it's a negotiation
yeah and and Dominic has been clear that
that's what that we would accept a
potential extension by a few months
subject to either a finite time limit or
a mechanism to extricate ourselves from
it if it meant breaking this impasse and
avoiding the very unattractive proposal
by the EU which is an indefinite customs
union and a limbo period which would
cause complete uncertainty and not on a
brexit just to be clear because I know
we can get quite far down in the weeds
so in those discussions but we're
talking here about the transition deal
extension to replace the e use backstop
not the UK's proposed backstop which is
to keep the whole of the UK in a costume
well we want we want a UK
I'd backstop alternatively so what our
proposal would would it was was a
temporary customs arrangement which
meant that the whole of the UK was
treated the same there wouldn't be a
border down the Irish Sea and we would
retain that essential integrity of the
United Kingdom completely reasonable and
something that this government is
duty-bound to deliver and the EU have
been unable to come halfway on that
proposal so we need to try and find an
alternative if we want to strike a deal
and ultimately if this does get us to a
deal which is what we all want then I'm
willing to explore it would you accept
any backstop if it didn't have a time
limit
well we've been clear we're not
accepting that you use proposal but what
about Kay's proposal and a backstop
would you be happy to accept that
without a time limit we need to have
finality we need to I'm someone who
campaigned to leave the European Union
I'm very optimistic about our country's
prospects outside of the EU and we need
to leave the customs you but does
financially in a state do you would you
accept it without a date written well we
need a date or a very clear mechanism or
clause in this agreement which enables
us to get out of it so then that needs
to provide assurance to people and
myself that we all need to know that a
way out of it if we cannot sign up to
something which is in perpetuity vague
and leaves us exposed to an indefinite
membership of the code that would be
without a date we need to look at the
details and see what comes forward and
there could be many options as to how we
reassure voters and we deliver on the
brics objectives okay take a step back
what this seems to mean is that we're
not going to be leaving the EU in
reality in March next year because the
backstop will be in place although be
the extended transition I mean when are
we going to be able to leave the EU as
you would see it as a brexit Eve's able
to strike her own trade deals able to
diverge from EU rules when's that going
to happen
well it is it is a settled legal
position it is enshrined in statute that
we are leaving the European Union on the
29th of March 2019 so are we going to be
able to strike trade deal firm then well
we will be under the terms of with the
withdrawal agreement that we
signed that we've we have nearly agreed
with the EU we will be able to negotiate
sign and ratify trade deals with third
countries like we've just heard the u.s.
not very very keen to negotiate with us
Singapore very keen to strike an
agreement with us so we will according
to the terms of this withdrawal
agreement during the implantation period
have this freedom for the first time in
40 years to negotiate sign and ratify
trade deals but they won't come into
effect until after the implementation
period okay now a few weeks ago I
interviewed your boss David Davis on
this show and we can just have a look at
how he describes the prime minister's
checkers deal this is how he described
it just wrong if we got checkers the
Europe issue wouldn't go away the
toothache we've had for 30 years on this
subject would still be there for another
20 years as someone who is a committed
brexit here is he right listen I was
very honored to work under David Davis
in the department and I have a lot of
respect for him as someone who achieved
a lot during his time in the post and
there are many views about checkers but
I am here in the government I am so what
she'll do then I see checkers as a
pragmatic proposal it takes us forward
in the negotiations it honors the
referendum result in that it ends free
movement of people it takes us out of
the Common Fisheries Policy I've got a
coastal constituency I've met many of
the fishermen there who have seen their
livelihoods decimated by the European
Union's Common Fisheries Policy checkers
takes us out of that it stops the Common
Agricultural Policy it stops us being
part of the jurisdiction of the ECJ and
it stops us sending billions of pounds a
year to the EU for me and and it means
we can have control over our rules when
it comes to services so I'm very
confident about checkers as a proposal
to move the negotiations forward but and
and I'm hopeful that we will strike a
deal with the EU ultimately what I'm
trying to work out as you are you know a
keen brexit here you a chair of the Arg
your kind of bricks that air colleagues
David Davis Boris Johnson Steve Baker
all resigned but here you are you're
being loyal you're defending checkers
are you
exit sleeper agent trying to work out
what the government's doing and telling
you mates and the back benches I've been
called many things but I haven't quite
been caught about Sophie I'm I'm here
because I wanted to live a brexit I'm
enthusiastic about our nation's
prospects outside of the EU we're gonna
be able to straight great trade deals
with other countries we're going to be
able to expand the markets for UK
businesses and exporters and
manufacturers there's huge demand out
there we'll be able to set our own rules
and regulations I think this is a great
prospect and opportunity for us and I'm
really enthusiastic about me playing a
part in helping to deliver that now
we've been talking a lot about policy
but we need to talk personality because
the front pages this morning are
absolutely brutal reading for the Prime
Minister and the Sunday Times says she's
entering the killing zone the mail quote
somebody's saying she needs to bring a
noose to the meeting of benches there
next week it's absolutely brutal has she
lost control of her party
no the Prime Minister is leading us
through is navigating this course
through what is unprecedented for our
country it's the biggest challenge that
we're facing support a to your
colleagues as they've used this this
brutal language I I you know colleagues
are free to express themselves in the
way they wish but I am very clear that
our party is stronger when it's united
and when our party is stronger when were
you know they seems like to the end of
the co ministry no I disagree with that
I think when I knock on doors in my
constituency I meet many people who have
who provide their full support for the
prime minister and just want her to get
on with the job and I think division in
our party does isn't great for our
country and it sends a really negative
message to our European and global
partners as well and so I just want
unity in our party I know that we all
believe in very similar values as
conservatives we know that the biggest
threat facing this country is a Jeremy
Corbyn government which no one wants
here it would ruin our country would
bankrupt our nation and it would
diminish our state place on the world
stage and I think that that should focus
our minds as conservatives and we should
you know and I know that many of us want
the same objectives and we feel
passionate
about the prospects for our country one
person who's often talked about as a
potential caretaker leader is David
Davis before she worked closely where do
you think he'd make a good Prime
Minister I am here supporting the the
current Prime Minister Teresa made
deliver brexit I know that she wants to
succeed succeed in this unprecedented
exercise that we're all facing and I'm
very pleased to be supporting her very
nicely sighs don't sorello government
thank you very much